[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to the installment of harry
potter theory
yes you read the title right in this
video
we're going to be exploring the harry
potter theory that argus filch
hogwarts caretaker and resident squibb
is in fact related to
dolores umbridge possibly the worst
thing to happen to harry potter
since vernon dursley argus filch was
born sometime before the year 1951
and while we don't have an exact date i
think that this feels somewhat accurate
filch is an intriguing character and
there isn't much information available
on filters history
all we know about him was he was born in
the british isles
and that he had one magical parent
despite having magical parentage on one
side
filch was born a squib in the year 1968
filch went on to assume the role of
hogwarts caretaker
succeeding the previous caretaker
apollyon pringle
filch has been roaming the halls of
hogwarts ever since
however phil shouldn't roam the hallways
alone he does it with his trusty feline
companion
mrs norris together they are always on
the lookout for students breaking the
rules
vildge is quite a misunderstood
character and he's mostly glossed over
in the films
he's painted in a very negative light
almost as if he is evil
but in reality filch is just bitter he
was born a non-magical man
into a magical world which i expect
would be exceptionally difficult
and though he doesn't hate the students
he does love to give them a hard time
which i suppose we can just let him have
i feel she doesn't really seem to get
along with
anyone except for mrs norris the two are
never apart
except for when they've temporarily
decided to scout out different areas of
the school
they seem to have a quasi-telepathic
connection however
in the order of the phoenix field
suddenly appears to have a positive
relationship
with another person dolores umbridge it
couldn't be a more unlikely pairing
dolores is an extremely prejudiced
advocate of blood purity
and filch is a half-blood squib but
oddly enough the pairing of filtration
during the period that she worked at
hogwarts
actually seemed appropriate dolores
umbridge was a british half-blood witch
born sometime before the year 1965
before 1965 is a bit vague but that's
all we're
given so she could have been 31 when
starting at hogwarts
or 61. it's quite unclear she was born
in the british isles
to one magical and one muggle parent her
father was a wizard by the name of
orford umbridge
her mother was a muggle named ellen
cracknell and her younger brother's name
is never actually revealed
dolores family life was complicated and
her family became a huge source of shame
for her
her father orford was a floor mapper at
the ministry of magic
where dolores would later work when she
was questioned on occasion
about her relationship to the floor
mopper at the ministry she would
vehemently deny
any connection with him in fact it's
later revealed
that those who did question her identity
or her father's
almost always had nasty things happen to
them
nasty things tended to happen to people
who asked about alfred
or anything that dolores did not like
talking about and people who wanted to
remain on her good side
pretended to believe her version of her
ancestry
i'm sure you can imagine what a terrible
person like umbridge
would think of a floor mopper however
dolores wasn't the root cause of all of
the issues in her family
as her father openly blamed her mother
for birthing a squib
the fact that their family had a squib
was shameful for him as well
and eventually caused the family to go
separate ways
ellen dolores mother moved back to the
muggle world with her son
and alfred remained in the magical world
with dolores
however it's worth noting that this
divide didn't happen until dolores was
15 years old
so she would have known both her mother
and brother quite well before the family
split up
okay so dolores umbridge's brother was a
squib
and he's never named filch is a squib
and his parents are never named
do you see what i'm getting at yes there
are some holes in this theory
but i think that it has some merit bear
with me in the 1995-1996
school year dolores umbridge was placed
back at hogwarts by the ministry of
magic
but first she worked as a defense
against the dark arts professor
as well as the hogwarts high inquisitor
then after some time
she replaced albus dumbledore as the
ministry was convinced that dumbledore
was acting mad
during her time at hogwarts she had
enormous power of the students
teachers curriculum and grounds for the
duration that she was there
she made the lives of the students
increasingly miserable she did
everything wrong
she would conduct unreasonable and
abusive punishments and she would speak
to all the students and staff members
condescendingly that is except for one
man filch
filch like umbridge took pleasure in
punishing students for their misdeeds
he wasn't quite as evil or sinister as
umbridge but he was certainly a little
bit deranged
and this quote highlights his similar
nature i bet you'll think twice about
breaking a school rule again
won't you eh oh yes hard work and pain
are the best teachers
if you ask me it's just a pity they let
the old punishments die out
i hang you by your wrists from the
ceiling for a few days i've got the
chains still in my office
keep them well oiled in case they're
ever needed right off we go
and don't think of running off now it'll
be worse for you if you do
a filtch was clearly not opposed to
corporal punishment
and we see the same sort of punishment
administered by umbridge
in the i will not tell lies seen in the
order of the phoenix
deep down you know that you deserve to
be punished
don't you mr potter gives you shivers
doesn't it
they both loved rules and i'm sure
you'll remember umbridge's
educational degrees which basically
forbid students from doing
anything educational decrees the school
were
essentially laws created by the ministry
of magic that enforced
standards at the school the introduction
of educational decrees
was instigated by umbridge and it
allowed her and the ministry to begin to
expel and
punish students for actions that would
have previously been
fine and while it's glossed over filch
actually implemented similar sorts of
rules
at least when he could and when it was
within his power the following quote
from dumbledore
supports this so now that we are all fed
and watered
i must once more ask for your attention
while i give it a few notices
mr filch the caretaker has asked me to
tell you that a list of objects
forbidden inside the castle
has this year been extended to include
screaming yo-yos
fanged frisbees and ever bashing
boomerangs the full list comprises some
437 items i believe
and can be viewed in mr filter's office
if anybody would like to check it
it was truly their shared enjoyment in
punishing students that helped fudge and
upbridge to bond
however i did notice that they seemed to
get along almost instantaneously
there was definitely a bit of an unusual
dynamic and felch clearly respected that
umbridge was his superior
but they got along very well anyway and
it almost seemed as if they already knew
each other
so did they my theory is that umbridge's
unnamed brother
is none other than argus filch first of
all i think
this may be one of the only reasons that
umbridge was able to tolerate filch
she was extremely prejudiced but somehow
filch
a squib slipped under her radar in that
respect
it's as if they knew each other already
and had some kind of rapport
umbridge and her brother who has never
been named lived together for 15 years
so it would only make sense that they
had some kind of relationship
we know that dolores had a younger
brother and the film portrayal of filch
seems to suggest that he's older but in
reality we don't actually know the birth
year of either of these characters
both have undefined birth dates in harry
potter canon which means that umbridge
could very well be older than filge
additionally filch is a squib and has
lived a bit of a hard life
which could have potentially taken a bit
of a toll on his physical appearance
umbridge though awful is very prim and
proper
and probably takes care of herself quite
well i just can't ignore the fact that
these characters are
a similar b got along
and c have gray areas in their family
history
it may be a bit of a stretch but i
really think that there is a reasonable
amount of evidence
to support the theory that they are in
fact related
what do you guys think are filch and
umbridge related
am i missing something here let me know
down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
you